all right everybody our first story
today conde nast wants employees to come
back to work but a bunch of the unions
are fighting it so here's a little
background if you don't know conde nest
uh produces something called print
magazines now you may never have
experienced these but they're available
at this thing called newsstands or in
the postal service which is a mail
service that you've also probably never
experienced if you're listening to this
publication i kid they do vogue wired
vanity fair the new yorker gq bon
appetit uh they bought pitchfork
and so uh they are a new york
institution they're pairing companies
called advanced publications it's a
private company uh they own a whole
bunch of reddit which they bought for a
song and now it's gonna throw billions
of dollars to their bottom line when
they go public at some point but they're
a private company that means most people
will not know their revenue profits et
cetera and they have a very long-term
view they're owned by a family
and so uh in a leaked metrics article uh
to the information in march of 2021
kanye nest had revenue of approximately
1.5 billion according to an unnamed
source uh information is pretty credible
so i would
not necessarily take that with a grain
of salt i might take it with five grains
of salt uh their ceo had said they were
unprofitable in 2020 but according to
this information article executives hope
to break even next year really tough to
be in the magazine business and to make
that conversion over to digital
uh well yesterday i was on twitter and i
saw that the new yorkers union uh had
posted on twitter the following thread
and i'll just read it to you uh last
week our rto working group met with
conde nast to express serious concerns
about their mandate to return to the
office on november 15th
the plan is unsafe
and conde is in violation of new yorker
union and p4k i guess that's pitchfork
union contracts and the status quo of
the wired union wired magazine honda
nasa is evading essential questions
about safety protocols and their vague
rto strategy return to office i guess
uh is insufficient in light of high
rates of transmission and a union that
demands a robust plan we therefore ask
kanji to rescind their rto date they
refuse friday's meeting management
implied that because we aren't in the
office we aren't actually working a
baseless bad faith insult particularly
given ceo roger lynch's recent
characterization of 2021 as a banner
year we are proud of our contracts
continents continue to pretend
that they can unilaterally change our
working conditions but they are wrong we
have already filed up charge for wire
union
owing to the company's unlawful
violation of status quo working
conditions we know our rights we're not
afraid
to assert them collectively okay so to
put this in context the question is are
we ever going to return to offices and
does an employer get to say we're
returning to offices now in new york
city the current seven day average cases
is under a thousand average for deaths
is nine
uh seven day average so essentially
people dying of covet or getting co die
might be you know some of them dying
with covid you know they were going to
die anyway they got covered
and of course some of them might
be unvaccinated i'm going to guess that
the debts are almost all unvaccinated so
it's uh
it's one of these situations where a
company does get to dictate you have to
come back to the office it's clearly a
low risk if you look at it statistically
it's very low risk
probably similar as this pandemic turns
into an endemic we're probably at the
point where going to work
is no different than going to
madison square garden to watch a knicks
game going to restaurants how different
and i'm just asking this as a question
uh how different is it going to a
restaurant which certainly these
employees are doing
or going shopping which certainly is
employees are doing or going to an
office probably no different now i'm not
saying that going to an office is the
be-all end-all but
if the employer
wants you to come to the office and
that's their decision well to the office
you will go
or you have the option of not working
there so the union can
you know make whatever statements they
want but it is the employer's choice
because i don't think
that this is high risk am i am i
sounding crazy to you uh i have seen
many people going to the lakers games
the knicks games they don't have masks
on i see people in restaurants with no
masks on
seems like as of today in new york city
it's reasonable to go to an office to
work and
if you were scared about that i mean i
don't know how closely packed together
they are but i know conde nast has a ton
of money and certainly they have tons of
office space so they could spread people
out they could have all kinds of
cleaning crews not that contacting with
a desk is how you get it and certainly
they could mandate to come back to the
office you have to have two shots or a
booster or even wear a mask could be
optional or not depending on i guess if
you have an office so i think
and i'm wondering this is the only
standoff i know about because here in
the silicon valley google apple facebook
amazon they all push their return to
work back to january
so let's just say that's
you know conde nast is demanding this
two weeks earlier and of course this is
all due to the delta variant and apple
was like hey let's have you come back
three days a week
tech is being incredibly incredibly
flexible so why
why is conde nast not being flexible why
are they picking this as the hill to die
on a couple of theories
one theory is maybe they want to lay
people off
maybe they believe that great magazines
and great content can only be made in an
office
so
let's say that they have those two
beliefs i'm guessing that those two
beliefs are true maybe they want to trim
the workforce
and maybe they believe that to make
great content to make great videos
to do photo shoots magazine spreads it's
a collaborative process and listen i was
a magazine editor for over 10 years i
can tell you it is a collaborative
process it would go better with people
in the office now if you're a writer and
you're just writing a story
now freelancers always did that from
home they didn't come to an office going
into an office and typing on a computer
is no different than typing on a
computer in your home or apartment so
it does seem for artists that it would
be pretty cool to be in an office
together
so you know the other difference here is
continuous losing money
in a you know negative spiral maybe or
in a dying industry or a challenged
industry in big tech
we had our most profitable year ever
so this to me seems like a really
interesting notable case for us to watch
because
i actually think what's going on here is
and i hate to be a cynic and you know
maybe i'll be proven wrong i think conde
nast probably wants to cut jobs
uh and maybe reduce their workforce so
this would be an interesting way to do
that is to just force people to go to
the office and i probably do think that
an old school company believes that
being in an office and discussing things
is better than being home and they
probably also think some people are
goofing off at home
i don't see that in tech
because
you know we have such high expectations
of employees i'm actually seeing
employees working harder and i think
burnout's a more acute problem i don't
know how
good conde nast is as an old-school
company at managing remote employees and
they're privately held and let's face it
they probably have old people who are
old school running each of these brands
and they probably think if you're not in
the office you're not working so it
could be a cultural thing but certainly
this is one to watch
because remember with apple you know
they expected employees to return three
days a week and they got massive
pushback they still don't have a hard
date they're waiting to see what happens
with delta and they had a couple of
petitions that returned you know a
thousand signatures you know their
petition crazy at apple now
amazon
has left returning to the office up to
individual teams so each team is going
to make a decision i think that's what
we're going to see for most companies is
that this is a negotiation
and so
let's have the negotiation occur on a
team by team basis and see how many
people leave so if my team
you know in amazon prime or amazon web
services doesn't come to the office and
people resign okay we got an early
warning system
so that's this grand dance that is
occurring
[Music]